bonjour je suis Jean bien adras je
travaille dans le bâtiment depuis 30 ans
j'adore ce métier j'ai été chef
d'entreprise à deux reprises j'ai 30 ans
d'expérience et model bâtiment j'ai
travaillé comme pour des entreprises
GTOI
je précise en qualité de sous-traitant
et pas mal aussi mes qualités
je dirais mon boulot et moi je l'adore
j'ai toujours rêvé été immodal bâtiment
j'ai toujours allumé à faire ce que je
fais je suis quelqu'un de très sérieux
je ne plaisante pas et j'aime bien que
les choses soient fait et moi dans
l'ensemble
avec moi on joue pas je suis rigoureux
et j'aime le travail en équipe je suis
disponible n'hésitez pas de m'appeler